this is how you turn a blue wave into a
ripple you don't apologize they just
kept kneecapping themselves and then
Democrats were like what are you doing
give me a crowbar
what do you think question of the day
was there really a blue wave how would
you rate this latest election the
midterms here um let me just before we
get to your opinion before we get to my
opinion the objective answer is no
democrats incredibly incredibly
confident optimistic and republicans
privately back to pessimism and thinking
the house is probably gone and talking
to maybe can a whole lot of the senate
but the blue wave feels longer now that
it did thirty days yes rankings
releasing right now give the democrats
even more reason to feel bullish about
their odds of taking the big prize
control but the house of representatives
midterm elections that will reveal
whether the much-discussed blue wave is
real hmm whether it is big enough to
deliver one or even both houses of
Congress the Democrats yeah it's also
scaled back from whether we might even
win the Senate why I would say it's it's
a couple of different take away let's
take away number three this wasn't a
historic election at all by any stretch
of the imagination for either party I
really do think this was as far as if
you're just looking at her politics win
some lose some Republicans picked up
some some governorships Democrats of
course they picked up how do we know we
have the final seat count in Congress
exactly has another tallying up some
more votes I thought there was one more
maybe token all right so it's in the 20s
but midterms very important to know
usually result in the party in power
losing seats yes every single time now
historically if you look at that
unpopular presidents it's been an
average of more than thirty somewhere
around thirty seven seats for unpopular
president swings President Obama lost
sixty three House seats and six Senate
seats that's what you would call
historic okay so I think I actually have
some nerves yeah Obama sixty three
Clinton fifty-two Eisenhower 48 for 48
Johnson 47 Truman forty-five bush in two
thousand six thirty Truman twenty-nine
so yeah these are significant numbers in
comparison actually Republicans did
really pretty well in only losing I
think it's twenty eight seats as a final
count in the house and then gaining some
Senate seats objectively the Blue Wave
that they it was it was more of a ripple
they got some seats but it wasn't
something that's going to be changing
the entire political landscape here's
some here's some realtor you're not
gonna hear this from the people who are
just just just the cheerleaders for
Donald Trump you're not gonna do this um
the people on the Left who want to said
oh there was a blue wave right I've seen
I've seen people saying I was a red wave
I was a blue know the truth is it was
win some lose some but here's here's the
Midwest if you look at that it's kind of
what I talked about with the last
general election let's not think that
the blue wall in the Midwest was broken
down by President Donald Trump because
they all of a sudden became Republicans
or conservatives they just didn't like
Hillary Clinton and they thought that
Donald Trump was gonna give them more
free crap because you're talking about
unions you are talking when you talk
about unions in the Midwest
okay particularly in Michigan you're
basically talking about glorified
welfare recipients and if it would have
been Bernie versus Donald Trump Bernie
would have won so let's not count on
that for Donald Trump in 2020 we see
that you're at the midterm when it goes
back to like more money please more
money please every single time they will
eat themselves alive completely take
away number two I think this is really
important and not a lot of people talk
about this to me the the single biggest
thing that Democrats the biggest factor
that Democrats thought would help them
undeniably would hurt them the most the
lynch mob being of brick kavanah that is
monumental it backfired beyond all it
was gonna be a blue wait until Brett
Kavanaugh yeah
and I think actually yeah all all
battleground states all swing state
Democrats who oppose Kavanagh every
single one was defeated Wow uh the one I
think it was mention who supported yeah
Cavanaugh reelected and he was reelected
I so I love this I love that there are
consequences for their actions because
that's how voters tell politicians how
they should act in the future right it's
not rice that's getting angry and then
going to the polls and reelecting the
people that made us angry they actually
voted him out of office there has to be
a price to pay when you screw around
with stuff like this right and I think
that's I think that is really important
that we're going to we'll get into more
kind of the cultural ramifications and a
little bit but again Cavanaugh they
thought was a deadlock they don't we're
coming in off of me - Harvey Weinstein
is a German cause be the German let's
just accuse this man of being a gang
rapists and we won't get him confirmed
will go and it will sail through the
midterms and then everyone said hold on
a second that could be my dad or my
brother or my son and I just want to say
right by the way again the FBI probe
nothing there is only evidence to the
exact opposite of what they've said
what's Christie
dr. rusty dr7 dr. Kristen Ford worshiped
you like 9.8 million and her GoFundMe
why would she lie no reason what possum
what possible motivation could she have
for lying
deal at twelve point seven million I
think a number just keeps going up like
I said I McDonald's how many frauds
served ah takeaway I think the main
takeaway here too is so mid midterms are
a little bit different than general
elections like 2016 more about strategy
definitely or about funding more about a
ground game looking at districts as
opposed to national elections which you
can at least factor in some cultural
outliers that's a president Donald Trump
one that's why the polls were much more
inaccurate in 2016 and this one because
yeah there's a cultural influence that
takes place again also much lower
turnout with midterms so you typically
have people who are much more
politically motivated people who are
more politically inclined people who
take an interest in the political
process with general elections that's
not necessarily the case the closest
thing we had to a general election I
would say countable two Trump Clinton
last night was baito Cruz yes this is a
huge this was it's the closest to it was
a test-tube exactly was the closest
thing to an auntie Trump Pro Hillary
celebrity but it's like we saw in the in
2016 full-on media assault on Cruz and
unwavering support for beta I mean they
pushed so hard for him I think we have a
collage here about exactly what the
night of the election after after after
voting and closed beyonce is like no but
I'm glad she was pushing we're all the
non-contributing ladies at ouch and by
the way Democrats raise 69 million
formula so I think almost 20 million
more than then Ted Cruz so again if you
look at this people are saying well
they're trying to flip it purple and if
you look at how they kind of won the
cities which paid that's not new that's
always how how Texas had won Cruz won
this election the same way he's won most
of his elections as far as which kind of
districts voted for him the difference
here is in front of us doesn't include
the free advertising no it sold there
Ellen what else Delmar not not afforded
to Cruz at all he still didn't win what
we said would happen is actually
happening I think Alyssa Milano tweeted
out earlier
hashtag bado 2020 like it's happening
already they
want him to run for president after he
got beat by Ted Cruz but the Nexus
dodged a bullet we've got to be honest
that was very close I hope our side is
seeing this we've talked about this
before and you know Beto's out there on
a skateboard and he's doing Ellen
Colbert ya need to see how they can
reach their audience yeah this is the
way it's done better at this is it I
mean networks and cable news with 72
year-olds buying pocket catheters that's
not that's the way to get to the eye I
gotta say when goal Wilford Brimley
comes out and talks about diabetes I
just found myself in a comfortable train
to sum this up last night historically
low gains for the opposition party the
primary issue like we talked about the
left that they if they thought was going
to turn the tide is actually what hurt
there blue wave Cavanaugh and finally if
you're going to look at this as some
kind of a cultural weather stick to see
which way I know whether six don't
measure which way the winds are blowing
at this point yeah you know I don't know
how weather stick works honestly I saw
one in Sky Mall and I thought how is
this gonna function it seems as though
this is very underpriced for some that
can tell me the future if you're going
to actually and babe when you to water
that's the water divination yeah but if
you're going to look at this culturally
as any kind of an indicator as to where
the results here are pretty clear the
leftist the elitist media a Hollywood
the entertainment complex was completely
rejected the petri dish for that was
bait overs Cruz and of course as you
look culturally in in the American
societal fabric at large Cavanaugh
Cavanaugh fado Cruz these are clear-cut
examples that people are still firmly in
the Trump camp and I'm not even talk
about conservatives I'm talking about
people who are saying you know what okay
I'm tired of appeasing the left again
appeasing crocodiles is futile I stalk
some conservatives come out and say well
you know what maybe Cavanaugh should
step down now so we can heal the nation
no no this is how you do it this is how
you turn a blue wave into a ripple you
don't apologize Trump won but yes he's
bombastic yes he's kind of an ass but
the last thing he did was apologize to
scumbags who would eat him alive anyway
and if you look at this election you see
the exact same trend what helped
Republicans what kind of stop what stops
the bleeding as it relates to the
Democrats gaining any kind of Cavanaugh
they shot themselves in the foot so
terrible analogy there because it really
was that they basically shot them and
they were bleeding more
Republicans were kind of they just kept
kneecapping themselves and then
Democrats were like what are you doing
give me that crowbar you could out call
inflict self-harm if you're gonna look
at this election you can look at the
micro politics you look at the macro
things haven't changed in style Trump
and I think if you compare it to even
the Tea Party with with Barack Obama
they overestimated their influence and
Barack Obama won in a pretty big
election pretty handily I think Donald
Trump wins handily going for it but you
tell me what you think is this is this a
victory is it a defeat and I don't know
I don't really care because we don't
have a crystal ball or a weather stick
to viewer you like Samantha bee of
course not because you actually made it
to this end card you are a miracle of
the Internet I would say subscriber hit
the notification button but I don't
really know what that means on YouTube
you might not get notified anyway but
you can join up at laterthe credit calm
slash mug club that's Michael this
wonderful hand etched mug and you get to
watch not only clips but the full
one-hour Daily Show every single day
that was redundant because I said daily
but every single day but we're gonna
keep it anyway because we shoot these
end cards a whole lot in one afternoon
we're scraping the bottom of the barrel
with this one